[Music]
my planet arrakis is so beautiful when
the sun is low
rolling over the sands you can see spice
in the air
the outsiders ravage our lands in front
of our eyes
their cruelty to my people
is all i've known
what's to become of our world
[Music]
a boy
duncan can i trust you something yes
always you know that
i've been having dreams
about a girl on a raccoon
i don't know what it means
dreams make good stories
but everything important happens when
we're awake
hey you put on some muscle i didn't
no
[Applause]
we are house atreides there is no call
we do not answer
there is no faith that we betrayed
smile gurney i am smiling
the emperor asks us to bring peace to
arrakis house atreides accepts
[Music]
you need to face your fears
come with me
you need to be ready
you've never met harkins before they're
not human they're brutal
the duke's son sees too much
is why you kill them all
god in heaven
[Music]
get everything with guns off the ground
go
this is an extermination
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight my demons
dad
what if i'm not the future of house of
treaties
a great man doesn't seek to lead
he's called to it
but if your answer is no
you'll still be the only thing i ever
needed you to be
my son
[Applause]
if anything happens
will you protect paul with my life
only together can we stand a chance
[Applause]
it's time
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
academy's visiting artist film series
film aid edition for writing i'm vanessa
taylor and today i will be speaking with
the screenwriters of dune eric roth john
spades and denny villeneuve who also
directed and produced the film
i am thrilled to be here today to have
the opportunity to talk with you all
about this beautiful film
um and i will just dive in because i
have so many questions
uh i would like to start with you eric
and i would love to know what kind of
dialogue you and denis had sort of going
into this as you approached your draft
um
well we started kind of blind in a way i
mean except for obviously denis we both
knew the book very well um
and you you had also had you also read
it a long time ago i know denis you had
read it when you were in your early
teens eric at what point had you come up
i read it when i was in my early teens
but then when denise talked to me about
doing it obviously reread it you know
thoroughly you know more than once and
um
uh wanted to see what were the pitfalls
and i also was asked to write a a long
treatment for the uh state
uh because they wanted to make sure we
weren't going to besmirch the the piece
you know and anyway take off on some
kind of flyer
um but uh
uh denis is uh a wonderful partner and
said uh he gave me the right to dream
you know and i take dreams and i go a
little bit far afield sometimes and uh
he also uh you know which we've talked
about a number of times i said what
would be most important to you and he
felt
to somehow
uh show the women as the importance of
the women in it and that make the peace
have a
female quality feminine quality that
would be in keeping with sand dunes you
know those kind of things and uh
so that the ben adjacer became
you know as important in the book and
maybe more important to what the
whole sort of uh theme of the movie is
so yeah and uh i think we
we tried to figure out a way to tell a
really you know a resounding story which
was given to us you know by frank
herbert and not to uh
go too far afield but yet to try in the
most you know concise way and uh and i'm
not the most concise writer so this was
a challenge and he always had academy
keep my feet on the ground
and um
uh and i will say uh just uh to go a
slightly step further maybe this would
be something to talk about down the line
this is
this is to me such a unique experience
because i've been involved with other
sort of writing teams that you know sort
of rewrote each other and work together
but this is the most seamless that i can
think of where people work to the best
of their abilities on the things that
they know how to do very well
or i don't think you can tell one from
the other
and so it's i think a really unique
thing for uh to see you know and so i'm
very proud of that for everybody
involved
uh i'll go to you next denise i'm
wondering
what you were looking for at this stage
in a collaborator
i asked eric at the beginning because uh
i was uh i had read the uh
several uh of
his previous work and i was like always
impressed by uh
the depth of his culture his reference
uh his link his relationship with
spirituality
and and and uh
also um
i
it's true that i i one thing that i i
love eric's writing is is
is uh how he uh approached femininity i
liked the idea that someone who had the
more of a
an approach of an historian
someone that
will approach this book
and with that
view so that's why i uh
a request the name i had in mind to
approach the beast i mean because then
frankly
uh
i don't know about uh john and john said
but you know i was as excited as
terrorized
and i needed someone with wisdom and and
experience to crack it at the beginning
right i would i would love in a moment
to go back eric to what you said about
pitfalls and ask you all about what
those pitfalls might have been that you
were trying to avoid um but first i
would love to know denise so you came in
i believe after eric and we're writing
on this which you don't always do on
your directing projects and i just
wondered
you know what you hoped to bring as you
began writing on this work
i uh i started making movies by writing
my own feature films my first four
feature films uh i was the
unique screenwriter on the four of them
but i uh as i i
as the more i learned about writing the
more i i i realized that how little i i
know and how much i needed
to share
writing with
other people and that my dream was to uh
after having directed few uh
movies written by by other writers my
dream fortune was to share the writing
with with uh
other writers more experience that are
tremendously more talented
but that i wanted to stay close to the
the object of the adaptation i wanted to
feel the the intimate uh the intimacy uh
uh to try to
[Music]
infuse
in an american engine
visual ideas that i that were on thing
right um
my dream was to try to bring back to the
surface
images
that uh i had uh dreamed of when i read
the book when i was 13 years old and and
i wanted those images to
to stay in relationship with those
images and try to
to uh uh
insufflate i don't know to suggest them
to
an eric and john as we were uh the
writing was moving forward and eric what
was very um
generous uh uh the idea was and i loved
that it was like a paradise for me to
take eric's work and add this
benediction to to
to just to shape it to uh not shaping
apologies not the right word it's just
that eric will agree that uh what he
brought was
uh
a very impressive screenplay but that
was a bit uh too ambitious for the for
for our our resources
and and and i had to add with this
benediction i i
took the lns i i wish not reshape but
play with it no you did no you did and
you did a uh
i must say i mean i'm look you know i've
worked with like 20 directors and i was
always i'm always sensitive the way you
know the directors do what they they
either do you know what they're supposed
to do as a director and you know had it
do that kind of thing but denis
really did writing on it i mean pretty
wonderful writing where he was it was
more than shaping to me i think you no
but it was like trying and and uh
uh thank you eric but it was a
for me so inspiring uh to see eric's
stake
on the material and it's something that
resonated to the whole process it was a
and but uh uh the deal was that i had a
rig for that draft
and then i was working and then uh of
course
uh i needed uh uh help uh uh and uh john
came and uh i did a tremendous amount of
work to uh uh
um
again dig into more and two characters
and it was like it needed it for me
i i i
and i felt that since the beginning that
we will need to be a lot of brains in
order to crack the novel
and and that a team that was the idea
there's a lot of movies that i love in
my life where when i was looking at the
credits at the end there were like five
screen writers that i admire and i was
like i was dreaming to have that kind of
relationship on the with the keyboard
that you have like collegiality and and
that's the thing i'm grateful that uh
it was
that case for june yeah i'm really it
was a privilege for me to work with both
of these uh gentlemen
and you said that when you were
approaching eric you were looking at him
almost as a historian and talked about
you know the other qualities he brought
to this what what were you looking for
from john as a collaborator
john is was uh first of all the
precision of his writing that a a
very impressive and there's something
john also
as deep as rick does but he has a deep
culture of the book he knows the book
more than anybody else upside down he
can he can recite past passage of the
book he says
it's like if he had participate to the
writing of the book himself and there
was something about that deep knowledge
of the book that i i needed to uh to
bring on board and also
um
to
uh
that
uh uh linked with errors that i was
looking for and and to bring in a
romanticism also that it was like a it i
think that uh
brian johnny brought the kind of
equilibrium with all the uh the eric
wrote
eric works sorry my work and john it
brings something that had the proper
equilibrium that's what i was saying
yeah i always say that he he put the
movie on its feet i mean it was uh
i'm not saying he brought it down to
earth but
but in other words he was able to
accomplish both in a way and uh and he
made one of the great i think wonderful
um
transformations making the one character
a black woman uh that was a man and i
think that was sort of an astounding
idea and uh
but when i read his draft you know
you're always very suspect what what
happened here what you know where did my
work go or something
i didn't i didn't feel that way because
i think he first of all was so true to
the book in this in the in the right
ways
and and understood what denis wanted and
he did he did such yeoman's work i mean
it was really it's really an incredible
uh task that i think he did and my hat's
completely often
sorry i'm just going to say i mean i'm
such i'm just a more fanciful writer
than john is and that doesn't mean
better but they're just
i take flights of fancy and
i won't say what we did but when i i
first wrote something and denise said
that's lovely and how we can afford the
rest of the movie
[Laughter]
and that was true but i think as i said
i think john really gave it the the
foundation for it uh that uh it makes
the movie uh stand up
so john i would love to hear from you
then about first of all it sounds like
you had a real history with this book
second of all
i cannot even imagine what it would be
like to know that you were going to come
into this process
after both eric and denise had been
working in it were you
i mean did did it feel crazy to be
i i also wonder you know i didn't ask uh
you others about this but it's so it's
so
famous and gigantic dune i mean was
there for any of you a sense of
intimidation
in the face of this material or not so
much it sounds like john you're really
knowledgeable about that material yeah
well if i'm i'm sorry john i would just
say mia was uh
afraid at the beginning and i remember
having a discussion with eric at the
beginning and anna i had
i've been so grateful
that eric took the helmet to the
at the beginning and and start
to really try to
tame the beast because uh i was uh uh
impressed yeah i was like a bit
paralyzed at the beginning i remember
yeah
that's what i wanted on my side
i did know the book very well i read it
fairly young at 12 or 13 and it was one
of those books i reread every summer
vacation for many years growing up so it
was an old friend wow um and i'd put it
aside for a long time but it was
shocking when i went back to it to
realize how well i still knew it and you
know there's i think there's something
about the the plasticity of the mind in
your youth and
was that exciting or intimidating that
that this was such a beloved book for
you
honestly it was pure excitement i mean
um it was exciting to be rubbing elbows
with giants like eric and denis
it's always exciting to
just to be in the company of people uh
with such bodies of work and such
stature
um and
and yet i was not nervous about it there
were challenges to solve but the biggest
one had been solved before i came aboard
uh by denise's decision to tackle the
novel
in two films right um
there is no way to fit
yoon into a single film even at a
lawrence of arabia running time
without
dire surgery without a level of editing
that would amount to amputation
uh but in two films
i think you can get to the pith of the
story there's been a lot of talk over
the years about dune as some sort of
uncrackable story or
um
unadaptable book i've never seen it
honestly um
you know a couple of
storied filmmakers have taken runs at it
i think all of those storied filmmakers
were less than perfectly suited to the
material despite their extraordinary
gifts um and there have been fountains
of creativity around those efforts um
but
dune as a cinematic story is not broken
there are things that i am afraid to
adapt or that i think are nearly
unadaptable there's a wonderful sci-fi
novel called the stars my destination
has been kicking around hollywood for
decades ever since it was written that
one might be unadaptable some things
nearly are um but dune was ready to be a
film especially in the present day when
the technology filmmaking is caught up
to the scope of the world so for me
honestly i was excited i wanted to roll
up my sleeves i was ready to jump in and
deeply reassured by the quality of my
partners
yes
um is there books sorry is there books i
would be curious to know
you a rick is there books that you think
that are
unadaptable
um
well the only thing
i wouldn't say a book this was stanley
kubrick said you could not make a movie
about the holocaust
yeah um he said that's uh
untouchable
um and they uh well i i could say
something nasty about another movie but
i won't
attempted the holocaust but um
i'm trying to think
maybe if i don't know maybe the bible
i don't know i don't know i've tried and
i you know it's
i don't know that's a great question uh
i i can name other books that they say
that you can't do maybe uh
you know a thousand years of solitude
and you know those yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i don't know
um so i i do want to go back to a couple
things you guys touched on but i first
wanted to pick up with john that i think
what denis must have been referring to
was lee kinds is that correct
why was it your impulse to make that
shift that he referred to
i mean we're looking broadly um for
justified and organic ways to strengthen
the female presence in the film uh dune
as a novel has some very powerful and
memorable female characters really
seminal female characters um
but it's still a mostly male book in a
in some ways a product of its time
so we were looking for opportunities and
the character of the kinds is a little
peculiar in several ways uh in the very
earliest
notebook drafts of dune liet kinds was
the protagonist
and
the
when herbert was first brainstorming the
book and this imperial ecologist trying
to solve the riddle of this impossible
ecosystem
uh and to tame a planet without killing
what made it special he was the hero
um and then over time he found his way i
don't know for how long that was the
case but certainly in early notebook
notes lead kinds was the protagonist um
and then he found his way to the story
of the atreides clan
um and
so there are ways in which liette
fits a little awkwardly in the story
there's a
um
spoilers for a moment there's a
relationship in the novel
that bears no fruit we find out that
liat kines
is actually the father of chani among
the fremen
um
which is very awkward in the
storytelling uh because then
charlie finds out
that leon kinds died right before she
and paul are kind of falling in love and
they have to process dad dying very
quickly and then pivot to falling in
love um
and then we never really talk about that
relationship again in the story it's
kind of a
a phantom limb
um and there was certainly it would only
be confusing to try to introduce and
then sweep away that relationship in the
narrow confines of a film
um
so the kind's only relationship that was
left in our book is really a
relationship to the planet of arrakis to
the ecosystem um and to
uh the desert tribes of the fremen uh
with whom lead has completely integrated
and
the message lieet brings is so
fundamentally maternal and about uh
healing a world and preserving a people
and
finding a way of integrating
the aboriginal tribes which
were so much a part of her life now and
this miraculous ecosystem that's evolved
on this planet that to make her a woman
almost felt
obvious after the fact that it almost as
if she should have been from the
beginning
um
and of course this is a human diaspora
ten thousand years in our future or more
um
so
you know anything that we would read in
a racial text should no longer apply um
it's not a it's not
a race blind universe but
certainly what we perceive as race
should have moved beyond any envelope we
have for it and people are identifying
much more strongly with their planets of
origin with the noble houses that govern
them with uh societies and orders they
belong to and so forth
yeah i think that this idea of changing
the gender of kinds was absolutely a
brilliant idea that
james
sorry john
came with
and i was very excited by this idea
because it happened at the moment where
i was feeling at this equilibrium
because eric had wrote
things that i was deeply in love with
which was
that he had
studied the past of the of lady jessica
her training as a benedict all that
feminine strength and that feminine
training was in the earlier draft
and for
reasons of storytelling i had to remove
but i always felt the pain of removing
those beautiful things that eric had
done that were uh
and still today i'm dreaming to shoot
that one in my life but it's a but uh uh
that disagreement brought
this
um
desire to to to find femininity
somewhere else and john came with this
uh this this idea
um
i'd love to go back just for a moment
for each of you to origins in the sense
of i understand that you each had a
connection with the book at a young age
but
what would you say for you you know
what is essential what
in terms of guiding principles of what
needed to be preserved
what is it about this piece of work what
is this fundamentally about that was so
meaningfully meaningful to you
um
you know that you felt this longing to
do it and and was it the same for each
of you would you each tell me that the
book and the movie are about the same
things or would you each perhaps have a
different answer
i will say that i will suspect that we
have all different answers because
the beauty of this book is is uh and
that's why i think it's a masterpiece is
that it has so many layers that you
discover according to your own life
experience when i read it at 13 years
old i didn't
see saw the same thing
that uh uh when i read it again at 20
and again at 30 something all right it's
it's it's a book that
conveys so many layers and ideas
for me one of the the most important
idea was this
the one that uh
a specific school the benedict sisters
are able to channel
ancient voice voice coming from their
genetic past the voice from their
ancestors
and to take lessons instead of of
transforming those voices those ghosts
into neurosis they are using them as a
tool to uh and transform it into a power
and that that for me is an idea that uh
really deeply spoke to me and that i
wanted to make sure that it would be uh
prominent in adaptation
what about for you eric well the book
was um
the book was so part and parcel of my
particular growing up the culture i'm
not i wouldn't say and just to be honest
the book was my favorite book i've ever
read
it didn't it didn't uh impact me quite
that way i mean i thought it was
astounding and the work he did was
prodigious and creating languages and
obviously the formation of this planet
and all the prescient things we learned
today but i mean the earth day began in
like 1968 so he was you know he was
still ahead of that but
people were very aware of you know kind
of the loss of water and everything um
but
um as you know from knowing me as well
as you do since you were a junior high
student um
uh you know i was kind of a hippie and
this book reflected my era
in in many many ways you know we don't
talk about drugs so much but that the
the point of view of uh
varying societies you know kind of
clashing in some ways uh what is it what
is the sense of violence what is the
beauty of uh you know
femininity of um
as we talked about dreams i mean all
these things the um
the uh prescient nature of the boy who
now has this kind of
uh which i i mean was i think that was
personal to me i guess i'd say about not
that i'm a prophet but that you know the
the idea of how what is what is it
coming to manhood and then what are your
what what do you have to then accomplish
uh when you set out then after that what
is that next journey right um yeah so i
mean it was uh you know for me it was it
wasn't this was a job but it was i think
an astounding job because of
it's also the history of the piece with
you know
some great people trying it and then
this whole challenge of
you know
what can i bring to this you know and so
anyway so i think it's just i think i
think they're both right john and denise
i think it's a prism from where you came
from
and uh i i sort of gravitated to the
family which i have a big family etc etc
and
and as i say this kind of you know my
favorite movie was 2001 you know so
that's that was kind of a different
point of view of
uh mortality if you will you know
and john what is it about for you
there's so much in it and you can go on
any number of deep dives and denise is
right that it's
also different books at different times
it's very different reading it as a as a
boy about paula tradie's age than it is
reading it now as the father of an
eight-year-old son um and i definitely
attached to different points in the
narrative now
but for me
the real soul of dune is almost an
abstraction
if you read most genre fantasy you tend
to find characters representing clear
and bold points of view
for honor you know for family whatever
it is um
[Music]
and in dune
every character has this
nuanced and many layered
appreciation
of their circumstance and their place in
the world
uh
dukalito atreides has a code of honor
and he believes in it um he has a family
that he loves dearly he is aware of the
imperium as a morally dubious enterprise
founded on
physical strength and the doctrine of
might makes right he knows that there
are tyrants abroad in the land he
is honorable and is aware that his
performance of honor is theater and that
it is good propaganda and it lends him
power it attracts him followers he's
aware that it's still honorable and that
that's a good thing he knows that this
will all end someday that he is not
always
um
you're not in always the good guy in any
one interaction they have a very
real-world grasp of the complexity of
their
positions they are trying to be good
people they are aware that they are
participating in
systems that are imperfect um and
systems that have darkness within them
they try to steer in the best directions
to certain some extent they
embrace a certain fatalism that this is
what they were born to that their
systems beyond their power to change but
at every level of the book jessica as a
benny jesuit
uh stilgar as a fremen
uh paul and lito atreides as noblemen
rulers of a planet uh
rivals of other great houses all of them
appreciate the complexity of their
position and will in private moments
philosophize with each other about that
it felt in that way
like real life
uh we all know that we love our families
desperately and that our families are a
little bit broken and have some baggage
and some skeletons you know we love what
we do for a living and it's a headache
and a drag
everything's like that we love ourselves
and we know the ways in which we fail um
dune seems to model that nuanced complex
multi-layered thinking that can
entertain contradictions
and complexities at every level of the
storytelling and when i first read it i
think i had never read a piece of
fiction in which characters thought like
that and if there was anything i was
hoping to preserve into the film it was
that sense of many layered comprehension
of the world
i would like to go back to this idea of
pitfalls because i found it so exciting
to hear about
um denny what were the greatest
challenges in
making this a script you've already
all of you have actually talked about
the difficulty of compressing this
um and and what you did in dividing it
up but are there other areas you know
are there areas where you think wow we
really did this exactly as i wanted and
some areas where you think oh i i i wish
i still had this or i
you know
eric's work that you wish was still in
it but what what was really really hard
here
but the thing is that uh i will still be
obvious the idea was that uh it was
important for me to honor honor the
dream that when i read the book to try
there i i had an appetite for that book
and i wanted the people who i'd love the
book as much as i did
will find some respect for uh of the
world of the poetry of the book
in the same time i wanted my mother to
understand the movie i wanted to to uh
to the people that don't know nothing
about this world will feel welcome
and uh so to balance
uh information there are so many
cultures and so many tribes in this in
this
and to to find the right balance so to
give enough you know it's like a
uh um and not uh
put uh
too much uh exposition at the beginning
that
that will crush the other the aliens
would feel crushed under the the
mountain for information that it was
that was probably the the
forming the main challenge i would say
that at the beginning of the book the
books start by saying uh some something
like uh beginnings are very delicate
times and i will say that definitely
how to open this movie was the the big
challenge how to approach it at the
beginning we tried to be more faithful
to the book
and realize quickly that not quickly not
quickly we realized at one point after a
lot of work that we had to deviate a
little bit
uh from the book in order to make a
softer a more gentle
introduction to the world so people will
have enough
uh
in their
enough knowledge to not feel lost
at the beginning here that's uh it's a
bit the boring answer but that's the
truth
what about for you eric what were the
pitfalls you saw going into it
well i find the
same pitfalls in a lot of science
fiction
as i say i'm not as steeped in it
um sometimes i find things hard to
believe
right
uh and i found some of that in this book
to be quite honest it's just my probably
skeptical nature thanks
and i love you for that
thank you i mean i like to poke sticks
and eyes you know a little bit
um
so uh
i think it was to
not to you know emphasize cliches you
know that sometimes arise um
uh and to make it uh as uh
literate as possible i mean you can you
know you can take other avenues
to make the people real like in any
movie so i mean i think i approached it
the way i do any job that uh you have
different voices of different people
that have different different
psychological aspects and come from
different places and
and it's it's really no different than
um
if you're writing a science i mean i
think i've said this once to denis
before that
i was once talking to francis coppola
about writing something and he said
science fiction thing and he said well
as long as you're not watching the
chandelier it's fine so you have the
same rules apply you know in other words
that to shakespeare anything else that
the characters have to resonate have to
some emotional balance and all those
things or imbalance and
so i'd say those are the same uh
problems and that like there is a weight
of the fact that it's doomed in other
words i would say i haven't adapted
anything
that i can think of that of that
consequence you know it's like the the
famous thing is that bad books make good
movies and not that is a bad book but
then i'm i'm safer with forrest gump you
know
or a bad play or something because you
can go off and flights are fancy and
bent as you will couldn't do that here
you know i think there was obligations
um
uh
so that and i think that thanks to denis
and john they were maintained i'm not
sure if it was left to my devices it
would be the same movie to be honest
with you but uh
and do you recall a particular scene
or element that gave you grief
no not really not really i think it was
no i think everything had its uh
challenges and also had its solutions um
i did i mean i i wish i had had john in
my right hand who knows a book so well i
did have a woman who was a phd in doom
that was her that's what i'm getting and
so she told me what was the gospel you
know according to her anyway and i
thought that was impressive and she she
didn't know the thing i think she was
helpful to me
um
but i i i mean i i guess i'm being
honest with you
i don't approach things very differently
from anything i decide to do it and the
bigger the bigger problem for me is a
decision to decide to do it
um because i don't want to really follow
my face you know um i'd rather that i
left with a nice legacy but anyway
thanks to these guys it ended up being
something special and denis was that for
you a difficult decision when you
decided to split this into two
it sounds like it was a necessary
decision but it also alters structurally
what you're doing
it was a very spontaneous
i think coming from an instinct of
survival
you said what am i going to do
say it's like it's like i remember once
i took the
the the the i made the deal with the
gender e and of course
first thing you do is that you go back
to the book and spontaneously and i get
i went back
first thing i said that we have to make
two movies
part one part two and and uh
and that was and it was not uh uh
i didn't have to convince nobody
everybody agreed spontaneously
and
and
now the the
the challenge was
where to end the first part and then
that was like a lot of exploration there
was different
ideas in the table how did you make that
decision what were some different points
you were considering
well as uh
john could be more eloquent than me
about that but i would say that there
there are there is in the book a natural
breaking point there's a moment where
there's a time lapse there's a time jump
sorry between uh and and that would have
been
a natural way to end the first part but
the problem with that is that it meant
that our main characters paul and
jessica
uh
had to be introduced to a new culture
and learn things and went to a process
of being
accepted by by the fremen
and that felt like the beginning of a
story it felt like it didn't feel like a
last act of a movie it felt like
suddenly we were starting something
opening a new door and it it felt uh
too
heavy uh to put that at the end of the
project it uh
really felt at this equilibrium and we
tried and and there was beauty in it but
it didn't uh
uh
quickly we realized that it would be
better to end us and discover going
toward this culture instead of embracing
it that's what i would say does it make
sense what i'm saying
yes
yes um yeah and john were you sort of
involved in that
calibration uh deeply and
we tried many things
yeah
and
we were trying to thread the needle in a
bunch of ways the
that time jump was the first obvious
target because if you can
go away after the first film and then
make a second movie and you come back
and it's two or three years later in
reality and it's also three years later
in the story everything works out
um you can have your actors as tanned
and bearded as you need them to be to be
themselves a few years older um so it
did seem like a natural target but
it
thrust us toward that lawrence of arabia
running time uh which can limit the life
and audience of a film
um
and as denise said it it was a kind of
big fourth act
yeah
what we did find i think in part we only
saw the clarity of it
having
winnowed the story of the first film
down to an elegant shape a lot of things
fell by the wayside the guiding logic
again and again proved that we are
following the atreides family and above
all we are following paul atreides
through a metamorphosis
and
everything that does not serve the
telling of the story of that
metamorphosis became de-emphasized even
things we dearly loved um
and when you focus so narrowly on that
clan and that boy
that age
then you see a three-act story a tragedy
of being drawn out of the world of the
familiar of contending in a strange new
land uh with sinister forces of breaking
with the family of the fall and then the
gleam of hope at the end when the
dynasty survives in him and in his
mother and that felt shakespearean it
felt like it had a natural arc and so it
started to feel more and more
alien to then
tell another whole leg of the story and
start new things uh because the tragedy
had defined itself but we really found
it by trying to make the story fit into
the first film and focusing within
increasing intensity on the family and
the hero
um and that showed us where the story
needed to stop in the very moment where
he's leaving one world and entering
another
wow
yeah you could see that being very
challenging
wow
um well i think it was also complicated
because
there there was a question of whether he
should shoot two movies at once
right and that was just an interesting
you know in one way you can save a lot
of money another way it can be a
disaster you know so uh there's some
practical considerations but when we
were dealing with the storytelling it
had to do with well where are we going
to end this you know even if we're
blending into movie two that you're
gonna release a year from now so it's
really an interesting uh you know
situation that resolved itself
fortunately
um
i am going to take a moment to ask about
a scene that i really loved and just see
if anyone can remember the origins of
this scene um i really enjoyed the scene
where duke lato has to rescue the crew
from the harvester
uh was that a
scene in the book i don't yes yeah it's
it's it's a very good interesting scene
where the three of us
uh had
an impact on that and it's a it's a
famous scene in the in the in the book
but in the book let's see that paul is
less involved is more in the back seat
is more like a
spectator yeah
and uh
[Music]
eric brought the idea of paul getting
out of the ernie doctor
bringing paul involved involving paul
with the rescue being on the ground the
idea was
that it would it will be his first
encounter with the deep desert that it
will have a resonance inside him like he
will
strangely feel like at home in this
foreign landscape and that that moment
reoriented the scene in a different way
it was more than just a a rescue it was
like an encounter with a spiritual
encounter with a desert and with that
creature that will come and then from
erica idea ideas john came and slightly
shifted where uh um
brought this this idea of paul having
hallucinations i think that that came
from john it's it's it's sometimes you
know the truth is
and it's a thing i love about filmmaking
is collective creativity meaning that
sometimes remember don't remember who
got the idea exactly so gentlemen if i'm
uh
because it's there's so much there's so
much decisions it doesn't matter
but at the end it's the movie you know
it's teamwork but i will say that it's a
beautiful scene a scene that is a good
example of collaborative that evolved in
a beautiful way to time some the roots
of the ideas and then evolve through to
different ends on the keyboard and i i'm
very i love that scene
yeah that is me
it's a very striking scene from the book
because dune is a novel that leaves a
lot of the of his biggest moments of
action off stage
and
you get reports of this great big piece
of action that just happened your
characters discussing the aftermath and
reacting
uh but he just wasn't very interested
for the most part in writing a lot of
big action set pieces in his books and
so they tended to be in the background
as like matte paintings uh and you get
actors in the foreground uh talking
about what it all means like theater
yeah exactly this was this is a scene in
the book that is operatically told as an
action set piece uh really one of the
only ones and i think it's one of the
scenes that everyone comes away from the
book remembering there are a few things
that people who've read the book once a
long time ago will tell you about and
they'll tell you about the gamja bar and
they'll tell you about the sand we're
meeting the sand crawler and they'll
remember that moment so it was an
exciting scene to focus on but there too
like every scene in the novel
it has too many layers and too many
conversations in it to fit into the film
and so there again it was a process of
iteratively finding the essence of the
sequence
and was this quite an iterative process
in general would you say you know
for all of you compared to other
projects films you've worked on was this
quite iterative were there many many
many many many many drafts or just sort
of yes okay uh yes yeah i mean i
eric antony can talk eric and talk about
his process with denis because that
preceded me
um
but for my part the shape of it was that
i came in and you know took the book
apart and did a big adaptive work of my
own which then amalgamated with eric and
denise work and pulled all of their
finest creative flights into it and sort
of mushed it together into one thing
and then denis and i turned that over
again and again and again four or five
times in these very intensely
collaborative writing sessions we'd lock
ourselves in a hotel suite for a week
and he would come and go and when he
left i'd write he'd come back the next
day and we'd talk
from nine till two in the afternoon
right until midnight and send to my
pages and go to sleep
and he'd come in the morning having read
them and we'd talk until two or three
and we'd do it again
um until by the end of the week he would
leave at two or three in the afternoon i
would instantly fall asleep and sleep
until midnight and wake up and then
write until six in the morning send in
my pages
now i'm very interested by this process
and i would love to know denis if you
have pursued this process in the past
um
no it was the first time that i was
working with uh uh i i it's not true i
had
wrote myself a screenplay with the help
of another writer uh
but uh after that i i came on board a
project that had been written already so
it was a different approach it was like
to try to bring a screenplay
closer to my sensibility
by rewriting with the writer
storyboarding rewriting again
but not
starting from scratch like that of with
eric and john it was it had been a long
time and i was missing that part of the
the the process i i it's uh writing is
so uh it's so difficult but it's so
beautiful i mean i'm grateful that i had
a chance to to work
yeah and even even on the side even if i
was just on the side i had our i had a
great fun watching eric and john uh
working it was for me it was fascinating
yeah at the very end of the process um
when there were particular points of the
movie there were focuses of
denise creative concentration
uh then there was a lot of over leaving
where the knee was like the conductor in
an orchestra um and there were things
eric came and touched and i came and
touched it right here line by line level
and just you know standing and standing
until the thing
yeah because at one point what what
happened like any movie was the reality
of the production a budget uh con
restrictions which is part of the
and then that's uh john came eric came
and we we it was like a sculpture at
that moment everybody was uh chipping in
to make sure that
it will uh finally add the most let's
see beautiful shape in the circumstances
now we all know the saying too many
cooks spoil the whatever it is
apparently i don't know the same right
but sounds like it sounds like the
opposite in this case to what do you
attribute then
is there anything to you know do you do
you know why is it simply that each of
you you had complementary skills or
perhaps personalities
but there was that the book as eric said
mentioned at the beginning
we had obligation toward the book and it
was like it's an object that has such a
strong persona
either you like or you don't like the
book it still has a strong personality
and and i think that it helped us to
shape i think that's my take on it but i
do think just since we're talking to
writers here i think
i think this is a unique situation i've
been through some as i said many of
these uh
where you have conflicting kind of
writing you know one person writes
different than the other and
um
and it can can get very kind of hairy
and and rewriting is very difficult um
because you're trying to maintain a tone
and not you know have a separate voice
and change everything i think denise
right i mean i think the book is such a
grounded centerpiece for this and then
everybody had some great respect for
uh what it was had to say what we would
like to say with it and uh and denis was
a wonderful uh maestro a wonderful
master of
keeping all the boats moving in line you
know so yeah it was it was a unique i'm
telling you i've had
a lot of them which didn't work out so
good you know but isn't it interesting
too because i don't think one can always
correlate those wonderful magical work
relationships with good films
i mean i'm agreeing i'm agreeing because
i think it's shocking that that is what
happened well varying voices don't you
know sometimes don't make one point of
view you know um i think people can take
advantage of that too that's a whole
different kind of machine
it's true yeah it's true with your
scenario i think i may have gone over my
time so i think i better announce
the q a with the academy gold alumni and
go to our first questioner haley bartels
hi everybody thank you so much for being
here this has been
amazing my brain is exploding and huge
congratulations on the film
so my question is for everyone here and
it's kind of a general world-building
question
um so when you were conceiving the
worlds of your films are you
intentionally
thinking of and constructing uh internal
elements that reflect sort of the
internal elements of your character's
arcane theme or to the world sort of
springfully formed as athena
i will see that your question is about
the uh the use of landscape or
architecture to express the internal uh
uh journey of the characters that's what
you're saying
yeah just the sort of integral elements
that exist in the world of the film as
you're creating that world yeah the the
i apologize maybe i'm misunderstanding
your question but definitely uh there
was like a landscape
was a very important uh component of the
storytelling here where
uh
the way if you look at the way the movie
evolves uh uh the color palette and and
the the the way we are embracing the
landscape at different moment ad
was
used as a way to
externalize uh
the
condition in which the main character
called because the idea was that we will
focus as much as possible
just the the the story on paul's point
of view in a perfect world i would have
made just the movie about paul and his
mother but we had to go outside from
time to time in order to understand the
story but
and um
definitely uh uh architecture and and
landscape were used
to uh in a cinematic way i think to
express and it's the beauty of doing
science fiction because you can create
everything so you have like the full
you're like a god you can create
all the elements you need in order to
express
uh uh
some psychological uh uh
component of the of the you i don't know
if what i'm saying makes sense in
english right now but
yeah
that's the thing i love about sci-fi is
that you you it's like a living
sculpture where you are actually having
an impact on but it would be the same
with any movies in fraca
it's a it's part of the the
beauty of finding
resonance into the elements or into the
landscape in order to help
the audience to
understand
characters training in their journey
all right um our next question is from
desmond jackson
you know if i may add
the story we're following is the story
of a boy
the deeper he goes into the desert the
more you learn about himself the more he
has an introspective journey it's a very
introspective movie so it's like
that landscape i had a tremendous impact
that's why the movie was shot with
massive wides and very intimate shots
there was nowhere in between but it's
like
it's really
embracing that
point of view of a boy
uh discovering
a new world a new culture and embracing
that culture
all right desmond
hi guys thank you so much y'all have
literally been dropping jen throughout
this whole session so thank you so much
and fantastic film
my question is also similar to hayley's
in terms of world building i wanted to
know if you guys had any specific
suggestions uh in terms of introducing
world and the rules and class systems
and races and different planet
structures and everything so like an
unfamiliar audience without being too
expository with the character's dialogue
that's it
if i were to talk about the pitfalls of
dune
um i would have talked about the rules
um
i grew up reading a ton of fantasy and
science fiction when i was just a kid
and then i got tired of it i put it away
and when i was in high school and
college i was reading literary fiction i
was going to be a novelist someday and i
didn't really come back to science
fiction until i started screenwriting
where there was an appetite for it and i
had a foundation and i ended up working
in this file but a lot of my heart was
in
the philosophical and very personal
investigations of literary fiction
um there was a way to write dune where
you kind of went deep in dungeons and
dragons-y about all the rules and the
orders and the people and just really
got into the weeds of the world building
and there can be fun in that
but there's very little poetry in it
and above all it gobbles oxygen in any
movie there's not much space movies are
small they are novellas and so
everything you put in kind of goes into
the expense of something else
and the more you are putting in
the tin makers guild and the dragons of
lycora and the nebulons of troy whatever
you've invented for your world the more
you talk about that the less your
characters are living and breathing in
front of the audience
and
so the beautiful guiding light in this
production was denis
and his desire to tell a story through
the pure language of cinema
and and that he's saying that about uh
one of the talkiest novels in science
fiction and he says my goal my ideal
here would be a nearly silent film
you thought he failed
i don't know as a compass needle
that guided us in the exposition of
everything um so to answer your question
very programmatically if you want to
build a fantasy world with intricate
rules do write them down get dungeons
and dragons about them have your
taxonomies your histories and then don't
ever talk about it you don't need to it
will color the work
because you know it it will change the
way your characters speak because you
know where they've come from you know
how they live it will be implied it will
be poetry it will be in the background
and that's where it should live what you
want to be doing is telling human
stories in the foreground and so you
want to be as economical as possible as
you
about
actually being explicit about any of
that world building
thank you um our next question is from
marlon da silva
thank you so much vanessa and thank you
all for this great insightful panel i've
learned so much a question i had
thinking about the movie was did you all
have any visual references to refer to
while writing the screenplay and how
were they helpful when bringing those
words to life
well
if i may i would just say uh the
something that was fascinating for me is
that when we started the the work
uh eric started the work and i was at
the time doing blade runner and i was
like overwhelmed
finishing the movie on time and i
remember that eric had done and still
today
those images haunted me as i shot the
movie he had done a beautiful research
historical research uh that involved
science fiction images but also
historical based on medieval research
and it really all those images uh helped
me to to i was at the time starting to
shape
the world i had images in myself but i
remember the influence of eric
research on this site that i thought was
really poetic and
insightful
and then when john came on board at the
time it was later so i had the time
to start concept art and and to uh at
the time to so when i i remember
sometimes
john was writing and saying but by the
way
what does it look like and then i was
showing him an image and then he was
like
it was either
it was like a curve it was interesting
that i was
drawing the movie as it was written and
all that say and then sometimes i was
sharing and it it both it was a dance
between the so that's what i wanted to
say i don't know
yeah
thank you
um and our last question is from magna
nagaraja
hi you got my name perfectly right
um so i really love the movie and thank
you so much for taking the time to speak
to us um
obviously the soundtrack is very
haunting
um but here's my question so
chinese character doesn't have like a
speaking part until like the last like
about 30 minutes of the film right but
she has such a huge presence throughout
the movie and i wanted to know if that's
something that you guys
wrote
or is that something that was like
directed
i remember is written
yes it was written i think it was i
think it's written to it
most extension
it was it was written the idea here was
that uh paul is obsessed with those
visions all the true and then he finally
uh when he finally meet her then there's
a birth of an uh an exchange a contact
that is made but of course all this is a
promises promise for the the second
movie it's like uh
it's a it's a
bet that we did uh with uh having at the
end just to
intro we introduce characters that and i
was praying that there would be a part
two okay
because otherwise would be weak
but uh yeah so i don't know if uh you
want to add something john i reckon i
think i think that intention was there
but i also think that the
the power
of chinese presence in the film
uh
is
it flows directly from cinema it's from
the very potent performance of
zendaya herself
and the way denim frames her again and
again in the language of dreams
um she is the character who most
interpenetrates
uh the real world that paul is
adventuring through and the prophetic
world that he's experiencing through his
unreliable glimpses of the future um and
so because she lives in both those
worlds she acquires a higher
significance and of course she greets us
at the top of the movie as her voice who
frames the historical conflict that will
play out throughout the film
one thing i will say
is that uh uh
with
i agree of course what
with
said but
i was as a director i was mesmerized by
his india by your presence by your power
the magnesium magnetism
yes and and i shot more uh i add more i
got uh
let's see artistically excited by by uh
this actress that i think is absolutely
uh
such a strong presence and a strength on
the screen and so i i i shot more but it
respected the frame that was written
that's what i would say but yeah there's
more images
more there's more in a way that the
the more i was shooting with this than
the the more i wanted to shoot so that's
why i'm looking forward to do part two
thank you so much
thank you all so much i think that
probably brings us to an end at exactly
501 i feel a sense of pride i won't lie
great job great job
thank you thank you all thank you
vanessa thank you it was love
thank you
thank you for participating in the
academy's visiting artist film series
film aid edition for writing
you